my lovely genius farce genius brain is
sponsored by better help you guys know
I've been on that better health tip for
quite a while because I love therapy
because it helps me navigate how tough
life is and sometimes we're faced with
tough choices and the path forward isn't
always clear because life be throwing
you freaking curve balls and that is my
whole life listen
trusting yourself to make decisions that
align with your vows is like anything
the more you practice it the easier it
gets it if you're thinking of starting
therapy give better help a try it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief question
here to get matched with the licensed
therapist and switch therapist at any
time for no additional charge let
therapy be your map with betterhealth
visit betterhealth.com jeans today to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com genius
I'm not saying every single teacher was
like this to me but there are definitely
teachers who kind of looked at me where
they felt that I wasn't going to amount
to anything and I'm not saying I didn't
give them good reason like when you when
you're that kid in class and all you're
doing is punching kids in the face and
then you're picking your ass and
spelling it to see what the flavor is
the [__] day you know I look I'm not
blaming those teachers for thinking that
I wasn't in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of The Genius brain podcast once
again this is very very weird I know you
are all used to seeing me in a studio
and like I said uh in the last podcast
the studio that I was in before that was
the last time you were going to see me
in there you're actually seeing uh we
just moved into the to the new spot
um I didn't get to schedule another
guess because moving was so [__]
crazy uh have you guys seen uh Marie
condo I [__] love that lady Marie
first of all it's kind of weird because
Marie Cano kind of looks like my very
first girlfriend so a little [__]
weird having this girl tell me what to
do and how to live my life don't like it
but it's okay but uh
well if you guys don't know who Marie
kondo is Marie kondo basically kind of
um is like a tidying up specialist this
cute little Japanese lady that comes in
and basically says you live like trash
in the nicest Japanese way possible she
just comes in and she goes okay you have
a lot of clutter it's super disorganized
and you don't know how to let go of
personal things that you either feel
like you need or you just you're hoarder
to a certain extent and once again I'm
oversimplifying this thing but she has a
specific method called the Marie condo
method and one of the things that I like
that she does is that before she throws
away things at her house or your house
you kind of look at the item and
appreciate what it was used for but you
have to be realistic with the object so
for example
when I was uh trying to throw away
things in the house
um I was doing this over a period of a
week because you know what happens is
that you you tend to collect a lot of
things in your life because you feel
like you're going to need it later right
and this honestly happens a lot to a lot
of people who grew up really poor or who
are immigrants
um or if you're a really poor immigrant
in my case I was [__] both so
um
you know when I was going around the
house I think
you know growing a poor like you just
didn't throw things away it's not
something that you would do right
because
having nice things and having things
useful to you so you don't have to bite
it is very important when you don't have
a lot of resources or money and so you
know I developed this habit over time
that you know my mom also has as well
even though she does tend to throw away
a lot of personal things that I really
like that's for another podcast but
um I had trouble throwing away things uh
throughout my whole life
I just
it's so dumb too like I like for example
I had this box of like USB like type B
or type A chords that hasn't been like
these HDM I had 46 HDMI cords why for
what purpose do I need for do I have 46
[__] TVs in my house no but I'm like
you know what one day I could use this I
could and that's like that immigrant
poor people mentality you always feel
like you could you could use everything
like if you grew up in an immigrant
Asian a household did anybody ever throw
away a container in your house ever did
anybody ever throw away a container no
you had cool whip you had Cool Whip
containers a Country Crock containers
and when you open it up it was never
butter or Cool Whip It was kimchi it was
it was like fermented [__] you would
open up like man I'm really uh I'm in
I'm feening for some butter and toast
you open up that uh Country Crock and
all of a sudden there's like pig feet
inside like [__] man like what is this
that's
the reality of being in a in an
immigrant household and so
having said that it was very very hard
for me to kind of throw away things and
when I started watching Marie kondo on
her show and I started reading up about
the Marie condo method it was more along
the lines of being realistic with the
things that you have and appreciating
the item for what it was used for at the
time right if I hadn't used something
within four to five years it obviously
can go it doesn't need to stick around
and I had a box of stuff that I haven't
I even knew it existed for maybe seven
to eight years but I just couldn't get
myself to give it to somebody or throw
it away or even sell it and I think once
again it's because of that poor
immigrant mentality you know
I will say this like
you know going through everything that I
was going through and trying to throw
away these things made me feel like I
was a bad person it's such a weird
feeling to have right
when you have objects that are
specifically tied to your childhood it's
hard to let it go
right because you feel like this
emotional attachment to something even
if you didn't use it or touch it in
years you just can't let it go
and I had to come to terms with the
reality of the situation of like look
David number one if you didn't use it in
years you're probably not going to use
it again saying this brings up memories
and I'm not talking about photos or
pictures or personal memorabilia I'm
talking about [__] wires and chords
like Let It Go so the whole past week
I've been purging and getting rid of
things and it you know it kind of
you know made me think to myself uh
specifically a lot about how I grew up
and how I didn't have a lot growing up
and now you know being in this house and
moving for the third time in three
[__] years I realized that I I lived
in abundance
and I always talk about this thing about
being grateful right and for me
gratitude is everything
I'm not saying I'm a great person I'm
obviously a piece of [__] uh I've been a
piece of [__] since day one but I'm just
kind of working on getting better but I
I look back at the things
that I didn't have growing up and I look
at where I am now and when I was younger
and I've said this before on a podcast
with Muriel I never thought that I could
do the things that I've done today when
I was younger you know when you're a kid
and people constantly just tell you that
you're dumb or you know even like people
in positions of power whether they were
teachers or Educators I'm not saying
every single teacher was like this to me
but there are definitely teachers who
kind of looked at me where they felt
that I wasn't going to amount to
anything and I'm not saying I didn't
give them good reason like when you when
you're that kid in class and all you're
doing is punching kids in the face and
then you're picking your ass and
spelling it to see what the flavor is
the [__] day you know I look I'm not
blaming those teachers for thinking that
I wasn't this you know the sharpest tool
in the shed but you know those type of
things do affect you later on and
um recently I talked about this where um
I actually did get diagnosed with ADHD
and listen I knew I had ADHD for the
longest time right and it actually kind
of sparked when Tim went and got himself
diagnosed and he and I tend to have very
very similar Tendencies especially when
it comes to a lot of our bad habits and
you know a big part of me even though I
knew that I probably did have ADHD I
didn't want to get diagnosed because I
was so scared that I was going to use
that assessment of myself as an excuse
and it's a habit that I feel that a lot
of people have me included that the
moment we find something that we can
kind of blame our bad habits on but
that's the first thing that we go to oh
if I it's my bad it's my ADHD oh did it
oh my bad that's my ADHD and I didn't
want to be that guy because then you
become that [__] annoying person
where every wrong thing that you do it's
never your fault right it's it's
something else and for me getting
diagnosed with this stuff it kind of
honestly it kind of scared me
I don't think I ever talked about the
the fear part about it I definitely
joked about it a lot and
you know when I went to get assessed for
ADHD and it was through like a video
call I went as far as to like I had my
argument ready to as to why I didn't
have it like we were you I was like
FaceTiming this lady and you know off
jump she goes oh so what makes you feel
you have ADHD I was actually I don't
feel like I have ADHD you feel what I'm
saying this and let me tell you why like
when I have a hobby right and there's
something that I really like I'm laser
focused and nothing can get me to stop
doing it until I complete that task and
she goes sweetie that is a clear example
of ADHD well [__]
well [__]
you [__] know and a lot of the things
that she was telling me kind of
made everything kind of um like all the
puzzles started to fit right and it kind
of felt weird hearing it from a
professional from a professional
standpoint and you know she was kind of
recommending that I take um it wasn't
Ritalin it's something else I forgot
what it was called
um and just take small doses of it when
I feel like I need to focus but I am not
I just don't want to take medication
I've gotten this far in life without it
and so what I've learned to do is kind
of set the right habits for no now that
I know that I have this and at times in
my life it can become a problem
um I now have a Google task list where I
write the tasks down that I need to get
done
um the next day and I put it all on this
checklist and I refer back to it
multiple multiple times throughout the
day and until I get that checklist done
the day is not done and has helped me
out a lot
um
if I could explain to you what ADHD is
like it's it's kind of weird right and
I'm and I know a lot of people out there
like when I told people I had ADHD a lot
of people decide to self-diagnose
himself right they're like oh I got it
too [__] you don't want this is okay
can I just say something this is kind of
annoying
[Music]
want ADHD like when I say I have ADHD
and everybody's like oh me too we're
twins [__] you don't [__] want ADHD
it actually kind of [__] sucks to be
honest with you if I could redo
something about myself I would get rid
of this [__] ADHD this attention
deficit hyper dick face thing going on I
I [__] hate it I am an unreliable
person
um to myself and to others and I hate
failing others because I can't focus I
[__] hate it so what other people get
excited that you know they're like oh
maybe I have it too trust me you don't
want it you do not want ADHD I'm not
saying that it's not manageable I'm not
saying that you should pity anybody who
has you shouldn't pity me either but it
is pretty [__] annoying
when I was younger
I think the hardest part of having this
was
people thinking that I was a bad kid or
they thought I was just incapable of
learning or paying attention
and
never knew about ADHD until I got older
and I'm almost kind of glad I didn't so
I didn't develop this habit of making it
an excuse
so I'm glad I got to I I kind of
survived all the criticism and people
not understanding who I am when I was
younger to make be who I am today but it
was [__] hard man
when I was a kid uh did I share this on
a podcast I'm not sure if I did um it's
kind of personal and it's something that
I don't like sharing but
maybe this might help you out I don't
know if you were like this when you were
a kid when I was younger man
um
I remember at times where
I would sit in class
and I just couldn't [__] Focus to
save my [__] life I was all over the
place I would sit there and I would try
to either memorize or focus on the
things that I had to focus on and then
my mind would scatter and go elsewhere
and then time would pass I don't know
where I'm at I'm like okay just focus on
the task at hand do this and I would
look around and look at everybody else
and everybody was so laser focused and
they would get their tasks done
immediately because they could focus on
the things that they needed to focus on
and I just couldn't do it and I remember
as a kid just like going home and saying
like dude why was I born so stupid like
why am I so dumb like why did God make
me so dumb like this isn't fair I'm
stupid and I would have these
conversations with myself as a kid I
don't think my parents even know this
[__] and I remember one time like I got
so frustrated that I couldn't focus I
took my my textbook and I started like
smacking my head with it like why the
[__] are you so dumb and it was hard for
me as a kid and
you know kind of like navigating this
thing and learning how to deal with it
has been kind of tough like
people sometimes say it's a superpower
right because when you you can kind of
start and stop a whole bunch of things
but there'd be times when I was younger
when I was very envious of other people
who could just sit and focus and I
wanted it so bad
um
I know a lot of people are huge
proponents of of taking medication for
this and you know I have thought about
it and I and I might take a low dose of
it's not called Ritalin it's called
something else I can't remember what it
is but
um
I have no problem with it if I
absolutely need it but I do believe that
um
I have been able to figure out a way for
me that makes this a lot more manageable
so for those of you out there who do
have ADHD or feel like you do have it
um I suggest you get self-diagnosed but
a lot of the times I feel like even with
personal people around me like they
almost want to get diagnosed so they can
use it as an excuse trust me ADHD sucks
like I I personally don't [__] like
it
um
and the fact that you want to sit there
and find an excuse for why you're a lazy
piece of [__] I don't know why you want
to do that
um but
like I said I'm not judging you like if
you got it you got it but try not to
self-diagnose yourself and I'm hoping
that you don't have it because it's
honestly hard to deal with unless you
get medicated for it or you figure out a
way that works for you for me as the
task list for me it's being super active
in the morning getting my wiggles out
and then kind of just doing a task going
away coming back to it and not beating
myself up for not being able to sit
through a task all the way through in
one instant and I'll just break it up
and make sure I get the tasks done
throughout the whole day because I am an
adult and I don't need to do things on
other people's time you know most of the
time
um that's basically what I've been
dealing with with this in the whole move
um I I do want to mention something
though today
um so I I did this video right it was
really quick uh Mariola and I uh to be
frank we have been our relationship has
been really good lately
um specifically I feel that our
relationship has been a lot better
because I have been better
um with
communicating with her which is
something that I had a lot of trouble
not not communicating emotions not
communicating how I feel all that stuff
is great but
ever since I had that diagnosis of ADHD
I started being able I was I am now able
to pick up these bad habits that I have
that I didn't know I had because my
brain was so scattered and because my
brain was so scattered and she would ask
me to do things and I would quote
unquote forget or I would get distracted
along the way it made her feel that she
wasn't important in my life that I would
prioritize other things over her
that I think for her it's she felt
lonely in this relationship at times to
be with a partner that it looks like
okay this guy is prioritizing his
Tomatoes like this [__] will
wake up at six or seven a.m to get his
Tomatoes done but if I ask something for
example to get I don't know like hey
when you stop by here can you remember
to get this and I wouldn't remember it
would make her feel as if that in the
total pull of of what's important she
was at the bottom and I never understood
and I and I kind of explained to her
like look this isn't
you are very important to me and to be
honest with you I don't know why I keep
forgetting these things that are that's
it's so simple and I don't get it and
what it was it was
honestly that ADHD diagnosis kind of put
everything together and now I I don't
remember the exact task that I have to
get done
um because I will get distracted
constantly but one thing that I can
remember if it's one thing a day is to
refer to the Google task list and then I
can look at it and then I'm reminded of
it again because I'd be getting
distracted so fast so once again I do
understand why she felt that she why she
felt the way that she felt and it was
very [__] valid because if I was in
her shoes I would feel the same this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends my lovely genius brain
listeners if you don't know already
I love better help you know uh signing
up for therapy is probably one of the
best things in my life because it's
helped me to become a better person and
I gotta tell you this my friends it is
fantastic having someone to talk to so I
can sort out my thoughts and my feelings
and let me tell you something sometimes
in life we're faced with tough choices
and the path forward isn't always clear
like you don't know what's going on if
you think you have everything figured
out let me tell you something man life
be always throwing you curve balls well
whether you're dealing with decisions
around career relationships or anything
else therapy helps you stay connected to
what you really want while you navigate
your life so you can move forward with
confidence and excitement uh I've used
better help for a long time specifically
because they're so accessible and I you
know you know in-person therapy is great
too but sometimes I don't have the time
for it and I need the help when I needed
at the comfort of my home and that's
what I love better help so if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
question you already get matched with
that licensed therapist and switch
therapist any time for no additional
charge let therapy be your map with
better help visit betterhelp.com today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help help.com genius
and so
so for example
um I
I got so pissed at myself one day
because all I had to do
was get these batteries from my from my
Adu the studio that I used to shoot the
podcast in but I would in between the
space from the main house to the back
Studio
like a [__] Labrador that sees like a
butterfly off in the distance I'd be
like what the [__] is that and I would
get this it took me like [__] four
hours to get these batteries because
every time I I went into the house I got
a glass of water I was like oh [__] the
batteries I would walk outside I would
see a tomato I'm like that leaf looks
like it's dying does this have powdery
mildew let me go Google this and I would
go into this Google spray of what I
could do to fix tomato an hour passes by
I'm like
that's right I had to go get the
batteries for the camera cool and then I
would go back in the house and get some
water because I was out in the sun
tending to these [__] Tomatoes I
would come back out and I'm like
look at that tomato
you forget four hours have passed and
then I wouldn't get these [__]
batteries and I got so pissed at myself
but that's how I basically developed the
whole Google task listing to kind of get
me back on track without having to
get medicated to help me focus a lot
better but to go back to like the
relationship thing between me and Mary
like we've been in such a really good
place and then earlier today I I posted
this thing of uh burial has this funny
thing where I'm not sure if your
partners do this whether it's your
husband or your wife
but there are certain people who don't
like following instructions right
I tend to be that way except for when it
comes to building things because I have
high anxiety so when I because of my
high anxiety I double check triple check
quadruple check things especially when I
build things because I don't want it to
[__] up because that has happened before
and it mentally [__] me when it doesn't
turn out the way that it's supposed to
so she has this Shelf that she hid from
me I've never seen and she knows I hate
like jock jeggy things so in Korean
Jackie Means like mismatched things and
so this girl has a shelf and you know
when you build Ikea things they have
like certain steps it's just like a
cheap shelf but
if you follow the steps the way that's
supposed to it's supposed to be built
the way that is supposed to look
so all the shelves were flipped the
other way so the brown saw dust particle
board thing was showing the back area
was all brown because she flipped it the
other way and we were cracking the [__]
up laughing I was like dude I have to
record this just so I can share it with
people and she and I were literally
crying laughing together it was such a
fun [__] moment and we've been able
to get into this place where we can joke
around a lot more we don't take things
personally we've been together for
almost nine years now and our
relationship has been really good I'm
not saying we don't have our ups and
downs but that was the moment that I was
just we were just cracking up laughing
together and lo and behold
as I put this video up and a lot of
people understood like they have
Partners like this as well there had to
be one [__] [__] made [__]
that had to put out this stupid [__]
comment that ruins everything and of
course I blocked this person but before
I blocked him I told them to shut the
[__] up so in this video I basically say
like yo
don't let your wife build things because
this is how they build it and I'm
specifically talking about my wife right
this girl puts on this whole diatribe
about like hey you know the way that you
used it for you had to humiliate your
wife
humiliate listen
are you [__] dumb do you literally
not see my wife crying from laughter
because she's legit enjoying herself
about how [__] funny this is
humiliate here's the problem with you
[__] out there specifically
when it comes to young girls who have
had terrible personal relationships that
haven't gone through therapy that
haven't had a moment coming to Jesus
moment of themselves by the way let me
just say this not just women young like
women and boys
who have not gone through therapy or
even like have somebody help therapize
them or help them go through their
emotions and feelings that you take
everything you see online as a personal
attack to you listen here [__] just
because you've had a terrible
relationship don't judge your
relationship
my relationship based on what you've
experienced in your shitty life okay
listen I empathize with you you might
have had those situations where you had
a boyfriend quote unquote humiliate you
or you might be somebody that just needs
to be told to shut the [__] up every now
and then you literally see my wife
cracking up laughing in the post I say I
love this woman so much because she
makes me laugh and the only thing you
took away from it was I can't believe
you humiliated your wife and you're
saying that women can't build things are
you [__] dumb
listen here I don't know what you went
through in your personal life but people
online are not responsible for how you
feel about your life and your shitty
relationships it is just a funny post
about two people who are in a somewhat
healthy relationship that are laughing
together about how stupid mistakes that
she made and at times I've made you
don't think she does that to me too you
stupid [__] idiot and listen I
understand I could have you know kept
her as a follower and said hey you know
what I don't know what you're going
through and you probably went through a
lot of things but listen we're in a
healthy relationship and this is how we
joke if you feel that way I'm sorry but
guess what [__] not today I'm not in
the [__] mood for it sometimes people
need to tell you to shut the [__] up and
I think a lot of influencers [__] up on
this type of stuff right
I actually saw an influencer that I
followed that did something that really
[__] pissed me off so this influencer
was just going around in a store and
they had like a drink right and they
were super excited that they had this
specific drink at this convenience store
like I love this and they hugged it and
this girl wrote to her saying like hey
um I'm a hypochondriac I have trouble
with germs and I think that you need to
be a lot more respectful when you touch
other things and you put it on you and
then you put it back on the Shelf
because you know pandemic even though
pandemic is technically over people are
acting like at least like Kobe didn't
exist let me tell you here
something here okay
people do not have to cater their lives
to your [__] Insanity do you
understand just because you are crazy
you are a hypochondriac that is a you
problem the world does not have to adapt
to your personal mental issues that you
haven't [__] dealt with by the way
[__] that can you should feel sorry for
the person that's rubbing it on them not
on the cam that you're about to receive
[__]
spin [__] probably already put
their mouth on it that [__] probably was
in a warehouse where a sweaty ass dude
with big ass man titties like these were
just rubbing all over it breathing their
hot ass breath on it maybe a
[__] sat on those cans before
they shipped it off to you you don't
[__] know and that's what you're
worried about no this is what actually
it wasn't actually the person who wrote
the comment that pissed me off it was
actually the influencer who wrote this
whole paragraph apologizing to them for
absolutely nothing
for nothing listen
so many of you out there are so scared
of offending people and getting canceled
that you will apologize for everything
for the things that you do not have to
apologize for and let me tell you
something you are not helping anybody or
the World by saying sorry to people who
do not deserve their apologies or your
apologies excuse me
it does nothing
you feed into their personal
insecurities you feed into their
insanity and you set a standard for
other influencers on this space that
they have to apologize for [__] that
they don't have to apologize for
apologize for the things that you mean
to apologize for make your [__] words
count if you are an influencer that
simply apologizes because you're afraid
that you're going to lose followers you
are the [__] problem
it is a never ending thing that happens
when you have to say sorry for things
that you shouldn't be sorry for
apologize for the things that count or
your apologies and your words mean
[__] nothing did you seriously say
sorry because you hugged the [__]
soda can and you put it back
maybe you should have responded hey this
can has been everywhere me hugging it is
not going to affect it so listen you're
a hypochondriac that's something that
you personally have to deal with and I
do not have to cater to your Insanity
that probably would have been the
appropriate response because but you're
once again you're so afraid of offending
people you're so afraid of that somebody
even if they're wrong that you're going
to hurt their feelings because of your
[__] brand this is what you do I've
talked to another influencer who
apologized for doing a Filipino accent
when they're [__] Filipino
why that person was AJ Raphael AJ I I
like I messaged this dude and I look
they just one of the sweetest [__]
guys ever
but sometimes because of his sweetness a
lot of people kind of like try to punk
him and you guys shouldn't try to punk
AJ he's like the [__] nicest dude
ever get off his [__] nuts but the
problem was sometimes with AJ because
he's so nice like he definitely
as a kind human being he doesn't want
people to feel like he's punching down
and I already hate that phrase punching
down as it is you know and he's saying a
song where he did a Filipino accent and
then he had to put out a public apology
apology apologizing for doing a Filipino
accent when he's [__] Filipino hey
bro and I'm and I texted him I was like
hey
stop [__] apologizing for everything
who do you think you're helping that one
or two or three individuals that feel
like they have power over you because
they feel that everything should be
catered to them because they never want
to be offended by anything [__] those
people you are okay you are perfectly
fine
listen
young lady I don't know what it is
but you felt the need to tell me
that
I humiliated my wife
and by the way just because you use
extreme words to describe an emotion
that'll incite a certain emotion out of
people because I know you wrote that so
other people can read on it read it and
then chime in on how you feel so you
were very selective about your [__]
words to try and go ahead and make me
feel bad for joking around with my wife
a joke that she was a part of a post
that she approved even to the point
where she went and she watched back the
video herself and she was cracking up
crying laughing because it was so funny
do not put your personal [__] onto
everybody else it is not our
responsibility to make you feel good
about your shitty relationships and your
personal situation we can be there to
help we can try our best but baby girl
my life is great my relationship with my
wife has never been this good
um and we have been working on our stuff
we have been going through couples
counseling and therapy we have been
talking to each other and my God the
idea that you feel like you could step
in and tell me how to how to I don't
know have fun with my wife is so [__]
unreal especially when she is a willing
participant that's enjoying joking
around and don't even bring up the [__]
that she roasts me about right because
what because if she was roasting me
right what would be your response men
are trash
right if she was making fun of me you
know guys they never know how to do
anything and guess what I'm okay with
those jokes because those generalities
are pretty [__] funny and can be
somewhat [__] true it's okay take a
[__] joke especially when it's not
malicious do you understand shut the
[__] up sit down think about what you
did and I love you
I hope you get better from this I
appreciate you either way but you're
still [__] blocked because you said
something stupid and it pissed me off
well guys I'm almost about to wrap up
this podcast but I do want to talk about
one more thing dude
did you all hear about [__] Jamie
Foxx yikes do for the longest time we
didn't know what happened with Jamie
Foxx but I'm actually really glad that
he finally put out a post and watching
Jamie Foxx
um
put this post out talking about his
personal health and
what he's been going through obviously
not through the specifics but if you if
you watch the clip it is [__]
emotional and I gotta tell you man like
it definitely definitely kind of [__]
me up a little bit because
he basically alluded to the fact that he
was going through a lot of complications
even after he thought he was getting
better while he was in the hospital and
a lot of positive messages really
touched and helping get uh get through
it
and Jamie Foxx to me is actually one of
my heroes because he is
uh critically acclaimed actor an amazing
stand-up comic an amazing musician and
kind of everything that I wanted to be
growing up and if we had lost them I
think I probably would have broke down
and cried too because the way he has
influenced me personally as an artist I
could never repay him back and it would
suck to have lost somebody who was so
impactful in in a positive way
especially if there was comedy and music
if we lost him that early it would have
been so sad but you know uh big
blessings to Jamie Foxx I'm so glad he's
doing well
um but definitely the thing that I love
Jamie I don't know before we end this
podcast if you guys haven't seen this
you have to look up Jamie Foxx roasting
another comic it is probably one of the
most brutal things that I've ever seen
in my life this dude rips into another
comic
so [__] bad it's like he legit it
almost looked like he was gonna make him
cry and I'll tell you this right now if
that was me I would never do stand-up
comedy again and that guy actually at a
standard comic it was really really
[__] funny but Jamie Foxx can do it
all
um I'm glad he's getting better man I'm
glad Jamie Foxx is alive Jamie I know I
know for a big fact you're never gonna
see this video but I love you very much
I appreciate you and I'm so glad that
you're getting healthier
um anyways guys that wraps up this quick
podcast it's about half an hour in I
love you very much stay positive to the
lady who decided to blame me for her
personal relationship issues uh I'm
sorry that you felt that way but I'm not
sorry that I said the things that I said
and I'm not sorry for posting that video
because it was [__] funny as [__]
everybody loved it but you so suck on
um my nut sack but in a in a negative
way you stupid idiot
and it by the way if you're watching
this on channel and you're a fan and
you're like um well [__] you uh David
I'm never gonna watch your [__] again
and I'm joining the Reddit that hates
you better buy bad
uh enjoy life [__] but I hope you get
better I hope you find somebody that
could help you through your problems and
either way God loves you but I don't
have to Junior's brain every Sundays at
12 p.m uh we'll be back to our regular
schedule next week I have guests booked
out I got you I'll see you all next time
love you very much David So out bye